are you
men are you uh
are you single yeah are you single
scarlett are you single that's the next
question are you single like a pringle
what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed we're going shopping
with sophia and sistine stallone do we
just become best friends yup
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sisters
sophia and sistine and scarlett
that's right baby i'm back
united it's so crazy first of all as you
could tell if you're watching the video
version of this podcast we are not in
our usual unwax studio and we have the
pleasure of scarlett stallone joining us
today on the podcast so therefore we are
shooting back at our old studio in
florida i am so excited to be back also
we are all under the same household
again which is even crazier yeah it's
really nice it's been a while since all
five of us yeah yeah i had dinner
together it's it's really hard being
away from you especially for me i mean i
don't know how sophia feels about it but
i yeah i don't care yes if you see it
yeah of course like you guys are
together 24 7. you guys are good we're
together all the time so it's really
nice to not only have you to break it up
but you're like my little best friend i
want to put you in my pocket all the
time and the only way we can communicate
today is through facetime yeah luckily
we're good with that and i don't even
like facetiming because every time i
facetime you guys i start crying
and then every time i see you again like
we reunite and it's only been a month
but it feels like two years i literally
start bawling in your arms
you know what i like seeing you cry for
me though is that weird you like seeing
me cry well no i like some odd
satisfaction well it just means you care
so much oh yeah because i don't show
that's what i'm saying doesn't show
anything emotion at all yeah i don't
know i feel loved i like it i know yeah
how's it been back here with all of us
together is it overwhelming or do you
like it you know not having space well
since i've moved across the country for
college i've just
you know i'm i'm really social so i can
make a lot of friends i can distract
myself but
that's why i hate calling or facetiming
you guys or seeing your faces because
i bottle all of that up and i get so
emotional because we've grown up so
close together all the time we've done
everything together so
even talking about it right now makes me
emotional knowing that i'm gonna
leave and
two weeks i definitely want to get into
your college life how you're adjusting
living away from home
how about this for the people that don't
know who you are we're gonna give you a
little bit of an intro
and i think we'll do some rapid fire
just so people you know easing get to
know me i would like to know you guys
let's write it in all right so
our guest today you've already been
introduced we're doing it again our
guest today is making her third
appearance on the unwax podcast you are
the number one requested guest by the
way wow there's more than mom and dad
did you guys ever see the dm that has
been sending every single day since
scarlet came on it's been like 150 days
and the guy says until you bring scarlet
back on i'm gonna keep writing this so
you can stop dming us about that because
everyone absolutely loves you so you're
back for the third time on the unboxed
podcast you are known for always having
the aux cord and sleeping in until 3 p.m
we have college student aspiring actress
and annoying little sister the fabulous
scarlett stallone
we love you so we love you so much
should we talk about what went down in
our living room oh my god i mean that
was probably the most slo-mo
tragic thing to happen in a long time it
was definitely not a christmas miracle
no it was a christmas tragedy you guys i
don't know if you when you watch our mom
on the show you probably see how loving
and affectionate and
definitely when you see that woman
you're like she probably brings a lot of
holiday spirit she puts so much effort
into this time of the year and that's
and especially since the five of us are
all together so she's going the extra
mile and so recently we'll just kind of
give a little spiel in the beginning she
bought this tree it looked like a giant
bush it was like the ugliest christmas
tree i have ever seen yeah it looks like
she cut it down herself yeah and she
showed us on facetime and i remember all
of us going er jen like where did you
get this it was like literally a shape
of a ball so i know she was so excited
when she facetimed me and i was in
college sitting in my dorm and she
facetimes me let's go look at my tray go
mom what is hitting him
it just it looks like a pom-pom it was
all all trunk
no brush coming out here yeah and just a
tiny ball at the top it didn't make any
sense
and this woman
made it her mission to physically like
cut it off with scissors shape it like a
tree put as many decorations and
ornaments and she's had these ornaments
for years 25 years 25 years since very
young i've seen the same freaking sienna
that stands next to our christmas tree
since i was a little girl and so she
really you could tell put her heart and
soul so when we came into town we're
like oh this looks a lot better
beautiful so sophia scarlet and i are
sitting in the living room there's
presents already under the tree
yesterday okay
and right there presents under the tree
it was oddly windy outside and we're
renovating the house so there was a tarp
covering the wall behind the christmas
tree someone opens the door a huge gust
of wind pushes the tarp therefore
pushing the tree over and it literally
looked like
the most dramatic movie
christmas holiday fail you've ever seen
we had time while the tree was falling
over to look at each other and look back
and go no
oh it was like a bad car accident like
you wanted to look away but you couldn't
and you just heard the shatters of
hundreds of ornaments just all of that
all of my mom's work all of the years
she's hides with all those ornaments she
was done
and not only that the tree was it's a
real tree so it had water underneath
water went all over the presents mom
wrapped so the paper was soaked and all
the presents were starting to come
undone and so you basically could see
like you would like your presence you
would lift the present and literally
water would be poured
do you see her face when she first
walked in oh my gosh it was just it
literally looked like someone shot her
dog it was the saddest
puppy dog face well we tried but she
wasn't home yet so we call our dad and
we said taste lie look what happened
here he goes don't tell your mom don't
tell her so we bring people in we try to
push it back up we're tapping it dry
we're trying to blow everything we're
trying to make it less obvious
everywhere she comes in when we're
probably 80 done but it still looks like
absolute [ __ ]
and i just felt so bad because i'm one
of those people when something
uncomfortable happens i start laughing
but not oh i didn't mean to
laugh to be rude i just was laughing
because it was so sad i just couldn't
believe what i just it was i was it was
funny it was kind of funny you have to
admit it we'll laugh about it in a
couple years and she will too but then
when i started laughing mom got so mad
at me she was like looking at all of us
and i didn't mean to be rude
well we were all laughing because i
think it was more so that of course of
course it was not because we were like
oh this is hilarious the tree fell mom
worked really hard it was that if
anyone's tree was gonna fall it was
gonna be ours it's gonna be our tree
okay so why don't we get into you
scarlett
we asked the listeners on our social
media
to ask you some rapid fire questions
just so people get to know you a little
bit better so i'm going to start firing
those off okay and you answer great all
right sophia why don't you kick it off
scarlett what are you studying in school
i am in the school of arts and sciences
studying bfa musical theater
and bfa basically stands for if you
don't know what that is it's bachelors
and fine arts
um
yeah that's that's what i'm studying she
does ballet and to see scarlet do ballet
i have live videos recorded on my phone
it's so funny generically you'd think a
ballerina is very
uh
tea and physique and very short and
flexible and you are very tall
and you have to sort of learn your
flexibility so it's kind of like you're
the anti arena no i i was because it's
such an intense program and the only way
you are graded in that class is if you
actually improve
and it doesn't matter if you're bad or
not or anything because kids
majority of my classes are really good
dancers i couldn't touch my toes in the
beginning of the year now i can bring my
leg up behind me i still can't touch my
toes that's right so i had to work
really hard to work on and so we'll get
into school schedule and
what the bfa entails but the next
question is any eyeliner eyelash
recommendations you do the perfect cat
eye which do i actually i was going to
say today
pretty good i actually i noticed that
too i've never been complimented by my
sisters on my makeup because i've never
been good at makeup i remember we
facetimed you when you were in the
beginning of college oh
darling can i just say i i'm going to
just say it right now i don't want her
makeup was
horrible i was about to fly fly to your
college
and rip those strip lashes off your face
but one was on your eyebrow yeah and
then one was one was okay so if you guys
have seen strip lashes one was by the
end of her eye where it was going down
so one's all the way up you look like a
tim burton character i've gone okay i
was never good at makeup and i really
wanted to improve myself i kind of
wanted to be different in college and
try new
things and strip laughter
well i think you were wearing because
you were very not into the whole strip
lash thing but i think a lot of girls in
your dorm and your year were doing that
at your school so yeah you were just
sort of doing it to fit in right yeah i
wasn't doing it because you know i kind
of walked to the beat of my own drum
when it comes to any kind of trends or
anything so i don't follow along but
when it comes to going out to parties at
night like college parties and stuff i
would want to
go overboard and try something different
and experience like experiment with
makeup yeah and
strip lashes absolutely not i'm never
doing that again i will do like
individual lashes the store the cvs
store-bought ones from like kiss so
that's what your recommendation is you
just stick those the little tiny
tiny they're not even strip lashes
they're individuals yeah the individual
by the way it's okay because my freshman
year my makeup was horrible too so it's
it's yeah it's a learning i'm just happy
that i learned
now like now i know it didn't take me
years to find out it's not good
you got the next question um what movie
or tv show character would you like to
marry scarlett
it could be a cartoon too
oh no cartoons no no
wow i i said you're walking
oh
[Laughter]
the first
all right so
staying on brand the next question is
what is your type
a lot of people asked this question what
is your type you guys are gonna
completely disagree with me and i know
exactly what you're gonna say my type is
but
i know that my type is anyone that i
just get along with okay someone that
can match my personality i don't really
care about looks i wouldn't complain if
a tall australian six foot six tall okay
walk through the door i would have mined
that i'm not in mind if some tall
man man with an accent
brunette preferably um walk through the
door and say
hey it'd have a great personality i
wouldn't i wouldn't care so you
basically just described it no no that
is not my type though i'm just saying
well accents
that are
completely random looks like i don't
really care what they look like as long
as they we just bounce off each other
because i have a very aggressive
personality so personality
because personality wise i would say
that you
lean towards more guys that can banter
with you which is yeah a very high
energy guy because some people have
energy like a leo someone that's
dominant that's astrology terms
yeah someone that's dominant and loud
and can handle my personality hmm so
speaking of leos
are you
men are you uh
are you single yeah you single scarlett
are you single that's the next question
are you single like a pringle because
she said she's into leo's specifically
loud confident it kind of sounds like
you're describing someone very specific
in your
life particular person that we probably
know about
no i'm not single oh my god
we did not know that
got you guys at home
whilst you are in a relationship yeah i
started
dating in a couple
couple
a couple months
no no no a couple weeks we
were seeing each other for
a couple months and
then officially made it official
so i know you guys probably want us to
ask more questions about this boyfriend
but we will later but we will later all
right um someone asked scarlet have you
ever levitated before
thank you dualipa i have okay
wait what someone actually asked
levitate like like float
obviously this girl over here has never
levitated
next question though okay um
favorite christmas movie
oh we were just watching it this morning
the holiday i just made my whole family
watch the holiday because with cameron
diaz unbeatable literally the best so
good
favorite makeup item
um
actually i was just using it i have it
on right now it's the tarte
juicy lip
in the color kind of reddish i'm
obsessed with it it feels like silk on
your lips i will 100 recommend this
product to anyone thank you sistine it
looks good on everybody it looks good on
everyone it feels good
it just doesn't it doesn't crease it's
it's like a lip gloss but a lipstick at
the same time
well scarlett wearing that juicy lip
gloss
if you were going to fight one of us oh
wait who do you think you can knock out
first in a boxing match me or sistine
yes scarlett yeah we're in the juicy lip
gloss oh you guys are very very strong
very strong
oh god my arm looks so tiny i know my i
don't know
that's do you see that oh honestly i
think you guys could both beat the [ __ ]
out of me oh my god i don't think i
don't think i can win between either of
you at least you know your place in this
family that's true all right scarlett
what is your fashion inspo again you're
getting a lot of
makeup fashion type questions because i
think you have a really unique style so
what is your fashionista where do you
pull from pinterest instagram
i follow a bunch of models and i think
their street style
is so good do you have one in particular
that you want to name
no i don't i i usually just follow kind
of what mom wears a lot too not what she
wears now but what she used to wear back
then
um i have a lot of photos
like
of her style
and like the 80s and 90s yeah 80s 90s um
yeah i kind of just follow whatever i
think just looks good and comfortable on
me i don't really have someone i kind of
just do my own thing love that but i do
follow a lot of pinterest stuff too okay
pinterest is a lifesaver i love
pinterest i do too
anything with like runway or anything
you know what's funny about pinterest
though i'm almost embarrassed to admit
that i have a pinterest because i feel
like it got wow i'm cool i love
pinterest
but no one actually admits to using it i
know the lawsuit no one admits it but
people when you say that you use it
everyone uses it i i personally think
the content on pinterest is much better
than oh it's superior oh 100
i have a bunch of like instagram or my
friends that have really good style and
i usually just kind of copy them but
pinterest i think of it as me using it
in sixth grade during school but then
now i've come back to it recently and
it's changed my style it's actually
helped me well i don't think there's
anything else like that out there think
about is there any other app that you
can
read like download photos and then they
would come up the same type of style
that you're interested in one way or the
other i think it's i just know that i
will never wear something that makes me
feel uncomfortable or if i don't feel
confident in it i will have a shitty
night like if i don't feel good in
something i don't care what other people
say about my style or anything like that
i always tell you when you call me and
say do you like this outfit or what
should i wear tonight what do i always
tell you
whatever makes you feel good so wear
whatever makes you feel good even if
it's a pair she goes jeans and a white
tank top she goes you can wear a damn
sweatshirt whatever makes you just feel
comfortable and good in your own skin
wear it well it was actually i just was
reminded by you have you guys seen that
tick tock that a lot of people are doing
where it's like confidence is everything
so girls will kind of like look not that
attractive on camera and then the moment
this one line in the song comes on they
pretend that they have this like exude
like this confidence be sexy yeah and
suddenly you're just like they look ten
times hotter yeah because you sometimes
i think we let the outfit wear us but if
you're wearing the outfit it's gonna you
know totally present completely
differently to people okay
okay scar who is meaner me or cecine
looks like
[Music]
seems a lot meaner
yeah oh i love you i love you equally
yes i completely agree yeah i told you
yeah seems a lot meaner because she's
that person that if she can she can diss
you and then you disrespect she goes are
you kidding me yeah and gets pissed off
and i i love you for that i love your
fire i love your passions
i know you're sensitive that's why
that's why i ignore it that's why i kind
of just smile and just wave it off don't
get mad back okay fair enough all right
scarlett if you could someone wrote this
if you could grow another body part that
you already have what would it be
oh my god why did i just think of boobs
for a second why did i just think about
four four oh no
well that's your first answer so we're
moving on with that one oh god
i'm trying to think what i would want
another one
maybe like an eyeball
like in the back of my head
gross because if you're brushing your
hair you're going to go screech oh that
like
yeah what would you put that's actually
i wouldn't want another arm
because then you have to have to figure
out clothes i would say another toe or
something
so you're kind of
okay another finger always cut it off
what if it keeps growing you have to
keep it on yeah it has to stand
ah
maybe another mouth
[Laughter]
so you don't have to eat in front of
guys because the girls get very nervous
some girls get very nervous about eating
in front of guys so they can just put
[Laughter]
or quite literally when you're talking
behind someone's back
[Laughter]
how has it been being away from your
best friend in college
oh i gotta sarah charlotte i miss her so
much i actually use charlotte you guys
they they both know my relationship with
charlotte because you know they are
together 24 7 and they moved out
together and everything so charlotte was
like the one person i had who basically
lived with me and i we all kind of
consider her family so
being away from her is
the hardest thing possible it's just
like she i treat her like a sister too
so whenever i facetime her i get very
emotional so you just have to keep in
contact we keep it we keep in contact
every day we try to call each other
every day you just gotta it's it's not
even hard if friendships are that strong
it's you can go
weeks and days or days and weeks without
even talking to each other and just when
you read kendo again it'll be all the
same that's how you know it's a good
friendship that's how you know i have to
say a lot of friendships that you have
in high school and especially people you
meet in college aren't ones that are
going to last much
farther from that education that you had
but when you do find a good one like
charlotte it's really important to keep
that relationship strong especially when
you're not in the same zip code yeah
shout out maya love you
shout out macap
love you girl okay
after the first week maybe two weeks did
you feel a little bit more acclimated to
the school or did you still feel like
you couldn't
fit in entirely um i
was you know how just just like every
other college student they're all trying
to fit in they're all trying to find
their people so i was feeling the same
exact way i i started with a huge group
of girls
half of them i didn't even know their
names but i started with a huge group of
girl a girl group it was cool and all
but
then the group started cutting down more
and more throughout the weeks but this
is the time where i was feeling really
really
uneasy with how i felt and how i fit in
in college in general because after that
whole orientation thing i just felt i
felt weird there i was being stared at
i've been here i heard
i every time i walked by like a like a
table or something outside i would hear
oh my god that's her and this and that
and i go i'm not famous i'm not famous i
don't deserve this fame i i'm i'm the
daughter of someone
who's famous but i'm not famous myself
and that's what really bugs me because i
didn't i don't deserve this attention
and i don't deserve all these looks and
stares and people talking about me when
i'm literally two feet away from them so
i felt really
out of place but it wasn't until
the girl group really cut down to solid
four people i had a lot of bumps in the
roads with girls and whatnot because
that is college you're going to go
through it's kind of like a big high
school that's what i think of it i mean
did you think yeah
i mean i could find a similar thing too
with like the whole dad thing i mean
it was not even just a dad thing but did
you kind of feel like yeah of course
college was like high school a little
bit yeah i mean like i only left the
school with like five really solid good
girls i think that's what everyone can
relate to no matter what school you go
to like even when you started a new
workplace you're gonna
try to fit in with everyone at the
office or everyone on your floor yeah
and then you realize that you know
sometimes the friendships that develop
the fastest aren't always the most
genuine yeah that's right it was it was
a girl group that started way too fast
way too comfortable getting right in and
i i just didn't like it i didn't like it
happens and then it gets kind of
complicated because everyone's then
trying to branch off and they get closer
with some people and other people and it
definitely is like a high school drama
yeah and the real friendships will
happen organically naturally you'll
gravitate towards the people that you
will like that you know you like but it
will just happen so
when a couple months later after finding
a good girl group and everything i had a
solid like
four or five really good close
girlfriends that i had and then i made a
bunch of guy friends as well on top of
that just a lot of friends in general
that i actually like being around so it
sounds like you're acclimated quite well
at this point but i remember the first
week
that
you know after we dropped you off and
i'd love to get into the feeling of that
but after we moved you in sophia
myself and my mom all helped you move
into your dorm we unpacked it we cleaned
it and then you know we left and that
was the last time we saw you the first
week for you i remember was really hard
and there were a lot of emotional phone
calls and a lot of you saying i don't
want to be here so describe with the
first week totally being alone and
independent
without any parents without any siblings
what was that like for you and living
with a complete stranger yeah well i'm
so thankful for my roommate she's the
easiest person to live with we got along
with each other very well and just
talking to your roommate just for a
piece of advice anyone's going into
college really talk to your roommate
about cleaning wise this you guys are
living together for a full year so talk
about groceries and this and that
talk about people that you're bringing
over you have to get very specific
because you guys are living in a 10
10 by 10 bedroom with literally our beds
are so close we can hold hands so
it's it's crazy so you have to really
communicate with them so she was great
so that's what made me feel a lot calmer
but
i think it was just
me
going into a school
not knowing anyone and i'm that person
where it's like
if i don't have someone and i don't have
someone to talk to at the school or
someone to go to to meet up with
i start panicking because i always need
to be with someone and i know that's not
a great trait and i need to learn how to
be by myself because i am very
independent but
just i felt so alone it wasn't that i
missed no really not not saying i don't
miss you guys but it's not like i didn't
i wanted to be back with my mom dad and
i wanted to go back i just think that i
wasn't in la anymore i moved across the
country i had no friends we moved in the
middle of my senior year to
across the country like i said i've
changed so it was just so much change
for me and i think that i also
personally didn't like the school as
much as i thought i was going to yeah
that's not at first but i think that you
know a lot of college kids can relate to
that too
yeah like they they go to the school and
they're like i don't know if i belong
here well it's like and it also you
never want to force something you're not
happy where you're at and you give it a
full year you can always
transfer and change like you shouldn't
force it but the most important thing
that you did and i'm happy you did was
you really tried to invest yourself and
acclimate yourself as best as you could
because you didn't want to give it a
fighting chance like you never should
take a place and not
give it an opportunity because you never
know who you're going to meet because
look at now although you know whether or
not you like the school so you have a
boyfriend you have a group of friends so
you still like your roommate
um and your parents are kind of clear
spanish but
it's still like it's it's good that you
did i mean try in the beginning like as
much as you try you have to if you just
give up fully then you'll fall into a
deep dark hole of sadness because you do
not have anyone around you you will push
the people that you like away from you
and that's what i saw myself doing i was
i felt so alone and every time someone
reached out to me or anything i would
feel s i i pushed them away i was being
rude yeah because i didn't trust anyone
at the school i don't i have really bad
trust issues and i didn't trust anyone
well
i don't entirely blame you for not
trusting complete strangers of course
everyone is going through the same
feelings and they're in the same
position in the same boat as you they're
all alone for the first time did you
expect independence to be
so difficult like i think
you're very strong and you've always
been a very independent kid but you've
always had us to fall back on so the
fact that we're not physically with you
for you to fall back on do you find it
really hard sometimes to have to solve
things for yourself and figure out your
way to go on your own
yeah completely because now i know that
all my mistakes that i make and i've
made a lot of mistakes but all i know
that with the freedom of independence
that i have not having anyone to fall
back on
i've made a lot of mistakes and i truly
truly know that i have to sit back by
myself in the dorm
and deal with it by myself and it feels
weird not going into one of your rooms
and crying to you about it or not going
to mom and talking to her or not having
dad there 24 7. and it's it was
very scary
but i've always loved to have the
independency
of my life and what everything i do and
i feel like that's
grown me
i feel like i'm a stronger better person
now and god i've
been a lot more mature i love that
because i
made so many mistakes and i had to learn
and deal with it by myself and one thing
i actually want to acknowledge is you're
doing a major that is very different
from anything i've ever taken and it's a
lot different from
most majors because when you're in bfa
from if people don't know what's
involved in school i can give you more
of it it's a lot of singing dancing
acting theater work yeah it's
approximately 11 classes and which is i
have to i'm i don't know if i'm going to
do it next semester
but
i do know that i wanted to study and
learn how to perform in every
different kind of way so i can do
anything because you love acting you
want to act i love acting but theater is
a different it is a whole another
technique
so for people that don't understand what
sophia i'm sure you can shed light on
this how many classes would a normal
college student take like what did you
do
um i would say you can take 16 units
like four classes four units you know um
or you can take more like four 16 to 20
units so scarlett's is significantly
higher so my my schedule is 11 classes
in total
23 credits a semester that's a lot that
is a lot that is that is so my friends
don't see me
throughout the week the whole entire
week they do not see me because i'm
constantly in class and doing homework
and working my ass off so how are you
able scarlett i mean that's really hard
you're a freshman at a new school you're
trying to make friends you're trying to
get to all your classes and do well in
performing how are you able to balance
your social life with your school life
my
having a social life it is
very very very important there are days
where i just do not want to get out of
bed the whole weekend all i want to do
is sleep and stay by myself but what
will that benefit me for anything
being
trapped in classes
all throughout the week and then on the
weekends just stay in my room and not do
anything and not make friends the thing
with college is that you have to you
have to
no you have to reach out that's every
man for himself not no one's gonna just
come up to you and just try to kiss your
ass and be best friends with you that's
not how it works that's not how life
works you have to be the one that makes
the connections you're the one who has
to push for relationships
that's not how life works no it's not i
realized that because i pushed myself
away from everyone like i said before
so
yeah i
believe that having a social life and
balancing school life is very very very
important so the way that you went about
it is you sort of forced yourself out of
bed
during moments that you could have
easily just just isolated yourself and
stay in see that's interesting i was
actually reading something really
interesting the other day
and i think this applies to all three of
us especially applies to our mom
um
is is how we handle stress
and i think you know all the time we are
stressed out and we're complaining about
this and
but then i looked up this article and it
said are you addicted to stress
and i was like that's interesting who
would want to be addicted to being
stressed out all the time because it's a
scary feeling so i wrote down some of
the signs that show if you are addicted
to stress and i'm going to read them off
and you guys let me know if any of these
apply to you or if all of them apply to
you i'm going to put my fingers okay my
fingers down if i yeah that way
you feel guilty when you try to relax
all of us you have a hard time getting
into the holiday mode
yep
you don't know how to do nothing
i don't want to do with myself you often
feel irritated
you think the reward will be greater if
you suffer now mm-hmm
you have a hard time disconnecting at
night
big yes oh my gosh it is so and the last
one is totally all of us you boast about
how busy you are oh my
i
talk about my schedule to my girlfriends
all the time at school they're probably
so we need to seek a therapist about
being stressed we're all so stressed
you know it's it's not even that i think
we just all love over achieving but the
problem is like you have to have a
balance like you can't just be on this
high stress all the time but you know
when you have sort of
a role model of someone that is showing
you what a good balance looks like that
would be easier but both of our parents
are such overachiever yeah
yeah workaholics so we only know that
it's not like they're pushing us to be
that way no it's just they actually tell
us to slow down but we don't like to
slow down and we can't we can't we're
raised like that i remember when i was
so stressed it was one time it was after
a long day of classes after five classes
one day
and
i was fine i worked from 9 00 a.m and
did not stop until
5 30 p.m
and
my i look in the mirror and i'm wearing
a tank top and there were hives all over
my chest and what was the first thing i
did i took a photo of it and sent it to
you because i wanted to show you how
stressed i am i have a question what is
each of your
things that you now know your stress
that your body does like for me it was
funny like for example like scott said
her body i always said the other day i'm
getting all these bumps on my hands like
on my knuckles and my fingers and it's
like yeah and every time i get over like
a level of stress i get all of these
random like red bumps it looks so gross
and no i have two um my chronic eye
twitch that listeners you listeners know
very well at this point so gross and
often sometimes when i'm sitting i'll
jolt my body and i'll shake yeah and
i've learned that that is signs of
stress and anxiety it doesn't mean
you're cold i know i would i have a
problem when i'm super stressed i it's
actually not that good i dig my nails
into my palms you do that you guys all
the time and i it just numbs me it helps
me i shouldn't be doing that and then i
also get very bad breakouts i mean not
hives all over my chest and i can't
sleep at night i would wake up just
sweating at night well i have to say
when you sent me the photo of your chest
with hives i the first thing i thought
was oh my god are you living with bed
bugs in your dorm yeah
i really thought i'm actually saying
that that's the thing and because your
dorm i'm not gonna lie was
a level of nasty show that it's hard to
describe
but
you somehow
judged it up very well and you actually
were telling me some really interesting
uh dorm hacks that you did to sort of
made your living situation livable yeah
so first the first thing i did was
my roommate this is why it's really good
to communicate with your roommate and
talk to them about this because my
roommate knows that i'm a clean freak
she knows i get mad about like if
there's trash anywhere or so always take
out the trash do not leave it because it
will smell it will stink up your room do
not get any
moldy not moldy sorry do not get any
too much fresh food and leave it in the
fridge unless you're going to eat it the
next day so
sometimes it stinks up the room if you
leave like microwaving like microwaving
yeah that's that's another thing but um
but my roommate loves like the she loves
indian food trader joe from trader joe's
spider loves it's fire it's so curious
so she loves it however so it doesn't
smell it smells actually pretty good in
her room sometimes with food wise but i
always get these but i'm very sensitive
with smell so i get
you know those car fresheners that you
put on the clips yeah those clips that
you put on like the air vents
or not the air vents of your car yeah
um
i clipped them all over my air vents so
i have about four
clip-on
febreze
air vent things so our room always just
smells fresh smells like ocean breeze
because you could be the neatest person
ever it's just for some reason that
building is so musky musky and
oh also getting a swiffer sweeper
because i'm not joking i don't know
where this dust comes from i dust and
vacuum our rug every
well some of it is yeah it better be
something because i cannot be producing
that much but you know what scarlett you
are you're doing it well and you're
making situations work and
oh here it goes it's really funny dust
is a mix of skin cells hair clothing
fibers bacteria dust mites bits of dead
bugs oh watch got chills oh soy sauce
yeah um
that's what you're cleaning you just
can't see it it just looks like white
things and yeah
yeah yeah
my god god i'm surprised not all my
skin's off the amount of dust that's in
my room
yeah so wrapping up the whole college
talk
i guess the final question really is
do you see yourself staying at the
school you're currently at or would you
prefer to transfer
you know loaded questions some
days where
i really like the school because i'm
having a good day and
i'm
having a good day with my friends and
i'm looking at all the people that i met
that are have been so nice to me and
have been so good to me and i will miss
them so much just knowing the fact that
i'm not gonna be with them next year
but at the same time
[Music]
i find more days where i'm sad and i
just wanna i want to transfer
back to the school i originally
was i got into so you'd like to go back
to california yeah
well i would personally love if you came
back to california because it's a hard
situation because i got into this my
dream school in california
for
fall semester and i was so i was
planning on going there since eighth
grade i've always wanted to go
and
then just plans changed
moved across the country but however i
did
i am very grateful that i moved yeah and
i did something
different i've been in la my whole
entire life she wanted to try something
new and they were like why not i got
into a great program and everything
and you know i've learned so much just
being across the country and living on
my own being there completely on my own
and it's just a whole new atmosphere and
everything so i'm super happy that i got
to do all of that because who's who's
gonna say like
are you guys ever gonna say oh i went to
college like
living half across the country away from
you guys or anything like i'm i was out
of la as much as i
love california
i do really want to go back but i did
want to leave there for at least a year
here's another tough question
we told you for years
for years that the number one rule
especially from someone that went to
college
is to not
get a boyfriend your freshman year
right
and i didn't
sistine didn't but of course
but of course
scarlett has to do her own thing she has
to i wasn't planning on it okay i really
was not planning on it coming into
freshman year i
i wanted to be single i wanted to focus
on myself
and there's been a couple of times where
i was asked to be in more of a
relationship and i've just turned it
down so it's like i'm basically the
bachelorette and the campus is my
bachelor yeah exactly
exactly
well let me so sofia and i we always
think that when you're starting such a
new chapter of your life yeah it's
important to figure yourself out we also
like to push good things away
that's true honestly don't listen i know
but the number one thing the number one
thing i say to guys when they want to go
like further into like more of a
relationship i go if i can't take care
of myself how do you how do you expect
no it's actually a problem because we i
feel like we all are the same way i mean
like now you guys have boyfriends but
anything that is remotely starting to
work out
if and it could even if it's like a
little bit complicated like maybe
they're across the country or maybe
they're a little older whatever it is we
just shut it down we go you know it's
just better
to sleep alone at night
yeah we i rejected the feeling well no
more so you see scarlet and i have got
it locked down sophia how does it feel
being the only single one in the group
right now
you know
you are basically me i am
it's been a long
winter she's been the hibernation she's
been hibernating
eating only old butter you know
she's stocked up for the winter
i am
is the thing when we're all single i
feel fine because you're alone and
you're alone but now
mom and dad are a couple
dating you're daughters all my friends
are dating everyone well also now no
this is funny sophia said that i heard
her saying this uh to mom the other day
and i was eavesdropping
why
wait i'm so excited to hear this because
you complain about this all the time and
this is just to reinforce how single you
are
what oh my gosh so be a system on that
she goes you know
i probably check facebook at least once
a week oh yeah and every time i check
facebook
i see about
a whole group maybe five posts of people
getting engaged everyone and i'm saying
what the hell
sophia's like i'm sitting i go i go she
goes my finger feels naked i go what the
hell is i'm a size seven i just at least
want like a like a cute promise right or
just like something
or just like sophia you haven't even
you're not even talking to someone no
okay let's go back to scarlet's now
so why don't you tell us a little bit
about him okay yeah um
we
were both very shocked we were both i'm
just as shocked as you guys we are very
shocked that we wanted to date
freshman year
and i guess that i
we kind of just bounced off each other
really well like i we connected
quickly i really really like him and i
think he feels the same how did he ask
you to be his girlfriend
um
he asked
nothing special i wanted to take me out
to dinner and ask then but then we were
both busy for the next the whole weekend
so he just because i wanted to take you
out and do something more special okay
so the thought was there the thought was
there i knew he wanted to but he just
asked and then there and i didn't i
didn't want like a grand asking but
it was it was nice i don't know why i
changed my mind and i'm actually happy
you found someone because i think that
when i changed my mind no no no no no no
no
no listen listen yeah
i like you happy this is why i changed i
was gonna say
that it's nice when you're feeling what
you're saying before in the episode that
you were feeling lonely and things like
it's it's hard transition when you're
don't have your person yeah and i think
that if you're doing that and you find
someone that is kind of in the same boat
he is not a cheater or a manhoe and you
know it's not going to be because look
dating in college it is a lot because
there's a lot of pretty girls a lot of
pretty guys like it gets a lot of
parties there's a lot of temptation and
so let's just say it's a healthy
relationship
go in and you're not right if if you are
happy with someone and you are you've
been seeing them for a minute and you
don't want to be with anyone else or
you're not even thinking about anyone
else then why not just do it is it the
label that freaks you out so much it's
not really different like if you
right yeah
that's what i'm scared of i i know
you're still the label but like if
you're thinking and constantly seeing
someone and you're going on dates and
whatnot
what is the point of just standing
around there and just being afraid to
get taken out yeah i agree i think we're
all the same when we don't like to just
date casually if we're gonna take us out
to dinner five six seven times
it needs to be progressing progressing
somewhere i don't want this to just
continue this poor boy had to deal with
me because i was so confused and i
didn't want to be in a relationship and
he knew that but then
i started liking him more and more and
more throughout the weeks so
but he was getting stressed out because
he goes okay so do you want to go
backwards or forwards and i go i think
we should just take a step back and then
he goes like i want to cha cha slide to
the left no no
no yeah and i go let's just take a step
back he goes what does that even mean at
this point i i understand like he goes i
will do whatever like what makes you
feel comfortable and good but
you know i like how he respected
my
craziness because i am alive your
timeline yeah i am a lot okay
i do resist layers to all of us that
take a lot of hammering a lot a lot of
chipping so if if someone can deal with
that then he is he is the person i'm so
excited for when we all hang out in
january and i get to fit the wheel and i
get to hear i know the most
freaking kissing noises
okay can i just say does anyone not like
the sound of
i'll tell you what sophia
was very upset with me the other day
i was giving a kiss goodbye if you will
and then right when the door closed you
made it a point to be so dramatic and
say that is the most disgusting sound
ever
sophia you haven't heard that sound
it's silent
it's a bit you're just jealous because
you're not hearing that sound or making
it yourself hey i have a question uh
your phone's ringing sophia
yeah answer it loves calling are you
going to pick up
yeah she just muted it
she hung up on love hey i have a
question scarlett though because yeah uh
you guys are planning to come to los
angeles together yeah january
are you going to let him meet the
parents
i you know what's really funny so i'm
okay with this
my chair actually keeps squeaking and
it's really annoying um
so my
feet give me
larry
[Music]
baby
okay let's ask that again
so
you and your boyfriend are coming to los
angeles in january
are you going to let him meet the
parents
yes
but
give it a second
here's the thing i i i'm i want him to
he wants to
there's no there's nothing the only
person that's holding back from meeting
the parents it's just a huge step it is
a huge it is a huge step and i like
where we're at right now you bulls
aren't going to be introducing your guys
for the first time parents
me too me too we'll do it together so
it's awesome you know what
i'm gonna be the goofy
[Laughter]
oh nice to meet you no i i'm gonna
defuse the bomb of mom asking for on
your questions and dad speaking zero
zero times
zero words well you know well you know
but you know actually i have to say this
you know what's
scarier for me than the parents
you guys
you two little devils i am so nervous
for him to meet you guys more than mom
and dad i know mom and dad will like him
easily well really i'll tell you you
guys are a different breed it's it's
scary for me
the thing is like your parents know you
but your sisters know you a different
way yeah
and and i will tell you straight up yeah
yeah we will be
because we want the best for you and we
see through this generation's bs
but i think dad will like him because
sophia and i have said this since day
one
scarlett i'm not gonna lie you're kind
of dating dad
i know that sounds crazy to say but the
similarities between your boyfriend and
your dad are uncanny oh like for example
what does he wear
he wears um i don't like the name of
this top it's called a wife beater the
white with a chain
and a backwards hat he's italian italian
he's basically a meatball dad's a
meatball that's an island
or lauren he's not from staten island
violet yeah okay
stop saying that
they're both like new york pigeons
no no no no it's not
okay i do see kind of a resemblance
between the two now that you say it and
they both have three letter names
slide
no um
got
that's gross okay that's creepy okay why
don't we wrap up this episode i thought
we'd bring in a fun little game and
i thought it summarizes you quite well
it's a quiz that i'm going to give you
and it's going to tell us if you are a
terrible sister or not okay what is what
it's called
it's called the terrible sister quiz i'm
going to ask you some questions and
you're going to say whether you're
guilty or innocent to doing that ready
have you ever borrowed your siblings
clothes that asked guilty guilty okay
yeah have you ever listened in on a
sibling a phone call okay guilty have
you ever bossed them around after your
parents put you in charge
innocent i've never had that power yep
have you ever
have you ever read their diary guilty
guilty too yeah guilty threat thank you
for the personal entertainment about
your breakup
excuse me
no it was from it wasn't even from your
last relationship it was from like a it
was [ __ ] quiet i don't write in a
diary no it was from like a crush in
eighth grade sophia it was not like
moving on it was an eighth grade crush
have you ever better have you ever saved
you need to put a lock on that [ __ ] i
know i write a lot have you ever saved
embarrassing photos of them to use for
blackmail
oh guilty i think we all have like have
you ever exposed them for telling a lie
or exaggerating something online
wait online have you ever exposed them
for telling a lie or exaggerating
something online guilty
have you ever awkwardly hung around them
and their friends waiting to be invited
oh my god oh my god
when you brought your guy friends from
um you were i was in love i was in like
my little catholic long skirt yeah you
were you loved the attack i was running
around after you guys have you ever
acted smug when your parents took your
side oh guilty i mean i think it's like
the other you're gonna fail this quiz uh
have you ever scratched them and left a
fingernail scratch
i know i have have you ever used their
expensive beauty hair or skincare
products without asking yes yesterday
guilty have you ever pulled their hair
guilty
have you ever pretended to cry to make
something someone feel bad guilty
have you ever sneaked into the room to
steal
a hair elastic that's a weird guilty
yeah
remember the black one with the little
gold at the end
yeah
that's just a bad person
that's just theft
they're big ones that's just that
i hate it when my friends use my hair
ties you mean mine
have you ever secretly recorded them
doing something embarrassing on your
phone i think you guys do it to me all
the time mostly so have you ever rubbed
it in their face when you were allowed
to do something they weren't
oh
guilty i don't remember last time but i
feel like i would have you ever
intentionally left hair on the shower
wall just to annoy them not not to annoy
them but i do that all the time i guess
now you leave hair on the shower wall i
cleaned it up have you ever she draws
pictures with it
i
do
sound like i'm the biggest loser ever oh
my god
okay
have you ever fought over a mutual
friend no no okay
have you ever spied on them when they
invited a romantic interest over yes oh
my god he used to watch him in the gym
when i wasn't there
um yes i did like to stalk sophia's wait
the funniest part is she had a photo of
him on her screensaver before okay
meeting him yeah not
[Laughter]
rest in peace no she's alive
the relationship the relationship
metaphorically he's dead
um have you ever told them they were an
accident
you have to me when you're younger
i probably did so innocent
and finally
have you ever secretly idolized them but
never let them know it oh guilty 100.
i'm not gonna make you guys
oh wow your results are in you are the
sister from hell
[Laughter]
okay it says you are a terrible sister
you love nothing more than to push your
siblings buttons steal their stuff and
get them to be honest these are okay
general questions that i think
somewhere in your cold heart you have
love for them i have deep love for all
of you that's why i cry every time i see
you well i think
ending it on that note is pretty perfect
yeah we are so happy you guys had the
opportunity to meet her again and see
you again because always when we do
these episodes with scarlett it is
always amigos it feels very homey and
comfortable i know i just like love
talking to you guys i can do this even
without the mics and naturally we do
this all the time we literally talk like
this for hours yeah in general so it
just feels so good to be sharing
everyone like i wanna i like showing
everyone like our relationship our
dynamic and everything well we love you
and this won't be the last time that you
guys will see scarlett don't miss me too
much make sure you follow her on social
media at scarlett stallone on instagram
make sure you follow our podcast unlocks
podcast on instagram tick tock our
youtube twitter am i forgetting anything
no and we will see you guys next tuesday
bye
[Music]
you